the white house has been caught editing
a transcript of donald trump's recent
photo op
attempt at looking like a very stable
genius to cover up
his total idiocy on immigration related
matters trump decided to host a
bipartisan meeting on immigration
meaning that there were democrats and
there were republicans in the room and
the idea was
to frame trump is just so knowledgeable
and articulate and it completely
backfired
anyway during the meeting you had
democratic california senator dianne
feinstein in the room
and she asked donald trump would he be
agreeable
to a clean daca bill what this means is
a bill that is only about daca
which would prevent the children of
undocumented immigrants from being
deported clean means
you don't wrap it up with other stuff
because when you combine different
political issues
into one bill you can get elected
officials who say i'm not supporting
these three things
because of this one thing that i
disagree with so the idea from dianne
feinstein was let's fix the problem with
just a clean daca bill let's fix
daca and not do anything else i'm going
to play the clip for you and pay very
close attention to what donald trump
says to dianne feinstein here
and i think and i don't know how you
would feel about this but i'd like to
ask the question
what about a clean daca bill now and
with a commitment that we go into
a comprehensive immigration reform
procedure like we did back or i remember
when kennedy was here and
it was really a major major effort
and it was a great disappointment that
it went nowhere
nowhere i have no problem i think that's
basically
what dick is saying we're going to come
out with daca we're going to do daca and
then we can start immediately on the
phase 2 which would be comprehensive
yeah i would like
i would like to president i think a lot
of people would like to see that pretty
clear right
after trump seems to say yes feinstein
followed up and we've got the exchange
to put up on the screen feinstein says
would you be agreeable to that and trump
says yeah i would like
i would like to do that so after this
meeting the white house puts out the
official transcript of the meeting
and that part of the conversation is
gone it's like it just didn't happen
evaporated never took place
in history uh the white house was called
out on it and after almost
a full day they added back in the
corrected version of the strat the
transcript
and the statement created a major
problem for trump because number one
tons of republicans don't want a clean
daca bill
number two it might seem trivial but
donald trump barely even understands
what's going on with immigration so he
doesn't even really know what it is he's
agreeing to
and of course trump's defenders are
going to say oh listen it was just an
error
the transcript it was just an erroneous
transcript
it just so happens that the transcript
errors
always help to somehow bolster trump or
uh reduce or suppress criticism of trump
there's this hilarious other example
um if i recall correctly trump cheats at
golf right
we know trump cheats at golf that's been
discussed many times but he clearly
takes real pride in the perception of
his golf skills
and former white house communications
director anthony scaramucci who lasted
in that job i think like six days
did he make it a week it was about a
week something like that uh
he once said scaramucci once said trump
he's seen
trump sink three foot putts which is not
really impressive like little kids who
have barely ever played golf can sink a
three-foot putt
and the initial transcript that was put
out quoted anthony scaramucci as having
said i've seen trump sink
30-foot putts which again it's not a big
deal in and of itself but this is the
official record of the presidency and
you're not supposed to mess around with
it
and it always somehow helps trump and
the funny thing is that whether it was
intentional or not
with any of these omissions but
especially talking about the the clean
daca bill i was thinking to myself does
it even really matter whether the record
is accurate because trump says things
all the time and then either pretends
never to have said them
or goes back on them or just says it's
because of democrats he's not going to
be able to do what he promised
it doesn't even really make that much
sense that they'd be that worried about
what trump said on the record
it's just funny because the whole point
of televising this meeting was to show
that one he's not experiencing cognitive
decline of course
and two to show that he's a great
negotiator and he has some clue
he failed on both fronts so much so that
they had to remove that from the
transcript
yeah and again we're we're inferring
that it was not an accident but
of course there is the possibility that
it was just a complete accident that
that was the one part
one part of the uh transcript that was
missing
anyway uh these errors never seem to be
uh they're always in trump's favor i
guess what i'm trying to say
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at
davidpakman.com
membership we are viewer supported
independent media
you can use the coupon code i voted 17
for a 40 percent discount off of your
membership